ils sont 25 sur scène à danser chanter
et déclamer ses bénévoles font partie de
l'association le cirque musical
leur projet est réinterprété sous forme
de comédie musicale l'histoire de
phinéas taylor barnum le créateur du
cirque moderne aux états unis c'est en
voyant le film the way touch oman avec
hugh jackman que le président de
l'association versaillaise a décidé de
lancer ce projet certains disent que
c'était un gredin et qu' il s'est servi
beaucoup de gens d'autres retiendront
plutôt que c'était quelqu'un qui avait
un grand coeur et qui s'est du coup
inspiré de ces personnes là et qui leur
a donné un lieu pour s'exprimer et donc
jeu on a retenu cette histoire vision
d'accueil
cette vision de partage sur une scène
autour d'un show il s'agit de la
première comédie musicale sous chapiteau
avec les personnes en coulisses cette
troupe d'amateurs et de semi
professionnel est composé d'une
quarantaine de bénévoles
au coeur de cette aventure artistique la
sublimation des différences l'interprète
de la chanson this is me moquer une
chanson qui parle vraiment de blessure
c'est la voilà quand les si la femme à
barbe se fait rejeter de la troupe
et d'ailleurs ça me touche énormément
fait de travailler texte de vraiment de
ça en excellent exercice de théâtre
d'aller
rechercher ses propres aux blessés en
fait c'est propre ça prend plus tard et
après douala d'être un peu écorché vif
en fait sur scène dix sept dates sont
programmées pour cette tournée d'automne
six représentations auront lieu à
versailles à partir du 19 octobre
[Musique]